Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
And, uh, I'm back indoors because
it's sometimes windy outside
and the sun is very bright and
so it's a bit less reliable.
So I'm back indoors.
I've hooked up my microphone to my
computer where I'm recording and
using Audacity rather than relying
on the recording of the iPhone.
I hope this produces better sound quality.
I want to talk today and maybe in the
next couple of videos about talking and
about mistakes, because all of us, when
we learn a language, we eventually,
we want to speak, uh, if we're in
a situation where we're able to use
whatever limited amount of the language
we have, you know, we'll typically do so.
Certainly when I was in Japan, as
soon as I could even say anything
to anyone I would try to do so.
In Vancouver, if I come across an Iranian
speaker, I'll try and say something in
Persian, So that's the main goal, but you
all know if you follow my videos, that
I'm very much a proponent of input-based
learning, listening and reading.
And the reason for that is simply that
when we're in a conversation and we don't
understand what people are saying, and we
don't have any words, it's, it's painful.
So, you know, I have started speaking
more in Persian and in Arabic, and
I've gone through periods where I
had a lot of online sessions, and
online sessions with tutors are great.
Actually, it's a phenomenal
capability that we have today.
And I want to salute italki which
has a wide range of teachers in
a tremendous range of languages.
So I can connect with
people, for example, in Iran.
Uh, from different cities.
So I'm getting to know different cities
in Iran, and they talk about where they
live and the food they eat and, and all
the while I'm speaking and in order to
speak well, you do have to speak a lot.
There's no getting around it.
And, uh, as you continue with
your input-based activities,
at least that's my strategy.
As I listen more and I read more and
I acquire more words and I understand
more then more and more I want to speak.
And as I go to speak, I, I discover
that, um, a lot of the words that
I've learned, I can't remember them
when I go to speak, but the more I
speak, the better I get at speaking.
So we do have to speak a lot.
And I even think that in order to
speak a language really well and
not be in danger of losing it you
have to possibly spend time in the
country where the language is spoken.
You need to speak so much that, that
you can eventually get as a sufficient
hold on that language that it won't,
it won't be frittered away by, by lack
of use, because I know that when I go
back into my Greek, Mini Stories are,
uh, you know, Mini Stories in Romanian
that there's a lot of words that I'm
going to have to learn again, because
I've forgotten them, which isn't a
problem to me because I have them there.
I can go back to them.
When I learn them again, I will
eventually know them better.
However speaking is a phenomenal
way of learning the language.
Now, some people suggest you
should speak from day one.
I've never quite understood that
because day one you know nothing.
So even if you engage in a
conversation, all you're doing is,
is, is, well, you can't say anything.
Uh, the person you're speaking to has to
explain everything that they're saying.
And my experience has been that when
I'm in a conversation and especially if
I don't understand very much, and then
the tutor tells me this is the word
for such-and-such, I can't remember it.
It's impossible to remember.
Uh, I find that it's much more useful
for me to hear it than to read it
and hear it again and read it again
and gradually allow the brain to
get used to the language that way.
But when you start speaking, whenever
that may be early in your learning or
later in your learning, listening is a
big part of speaking, paying attention
to what the speaker, and especially
if it's a native speaker, is saying.
So it's still very much an input-based
activity and the less of the language
you already have in you, the more of
an input-based activity the speaking
is, but it still can be quite painful,
uh, if you are with people and you
simply don't understand anything.
I guess there are people who
believe in this speak from
day one and who practice it.
I don't know how that works.
Uh, I have been, you know, uh, had, uh,
tutoring engagements at an early stage of
learning a language and I find it painful.
I can't wait until the session
is over because I can't really
understand what they're saying.
And I can't find any words.
At least if I have learned the words
through my input activities and can't
remember them, at least I have a hope
of eventually remembering them, but if
I have no idea what these words are, and
then they are given to me in the class,
there is no way I can remember them.
So of course, one of the things that
I do in my sessions with tutors is I
asked them the tutors to, uh, produce,
uh, a text file with a list of 10 or
15 or however many words they can.
Ideally they do it during the lesson.
So it doesn't become an extra
10, 15 minutes work for them.
All the words...
can't be all, but the words that I
used incorrectly, or couldn't remember,
or wasn't able to use or phrases, if
they can create a list of these 10,
15, 20, and in an ideal scenario,
record them, then send them to me.
Then I import these as lessons into
LingQ and, and, you know, I can then
review these over and over again.
I can review.
Uh, you know, the, these reports from a
lesson two months prior and gradually get
to know these words and start to use them.
But so the talking it's important to talk.
I think it's exciting now that I've
spoken to a couple of tutors in
Iran recently, one lives in Esfahan
one lives by the Caspian sea.
See there again, she gave me, we
must've mentioned the name of the city
where she lives three or four times.
I haven't seen it written out yet.
... maybe I can't remember it.
You know, we have to recognize that
it's not just because I'm old, you
can't remember stuff like that.
Uh, and so, but at any rate, I
have a tutor from Esfahan, a tutor
from up there near the Caspian sea.
I tutor from Tehran.
The tutor from up North, she
is originally from Larestan,
which is somewhere else in Iran.
So you're talking to people, you're
getting an understanding of the country,
of what is going on in that country,
of the geography of the country.
You're using words, you know, ideally
you're using words that you've learned.
You're picking up a few words.
You're practicing the art of
speaking because to speak well,
you have to practice speaking.
Uh, you, can't just all of a sudden
stop, you know, you've been listening
and reading now and engaging, you
know, with all the good things
that, that I do at LingQ and you
just go there and start speaking.
It doesn't work that way.
However, my experience has been that
you can activate it pretty quickly.
And very often I will study a language
with the purpose of going to the country.
And I did that in Romania.
I did that for Greek.
I did it with Czech and
with Russian, Ukrainian.
And when you're there
and you're able to...
You're sort of.
Immersed in it and, and, and working
hard to try to keep up with the
conversation that there is a sort of
a white heat there that, you know,
pushes you forward to that next level.
But, but you have to have a certain
minimum in order to take advantage
of that, say going into the country.
And similarly, before you can engage
with a tutor in a meaningful way, in my
opinion, you have to have invested in,
uh, you know, listening and reading.
And then these, uh, sessions where
you're talking, they are becoming an
opportunity then for you to go back
to your listening and reading and pay
attention to things that you missed.
So it's important to talk.
I don't think it matters when you talk.
Some people like to talk early.
I don't think there's such a thing as
talking from day one, because someone
has to give you somebody say, here's
how we say "hello, how are you?"
Then you say, "hello, how are you?"
It has to start with listening.
It doesn't start with speaking.
And so the only question is how much
listening and reading do you want
to do before you start speaking?
And that will depend on people's
inclinations, that will depend on
their situation, on their needs,
but at whatever point you started
speaking, a big part of the speaking
is still listening and paying attention
and getting the language into you.
Even as you practice the art of
speaking and get better at retrieving
the words and phrases that you have.
So that's all I wanted to say about
speaking, and I'm going to leave a
couple of videos you might look at
that are sort of relevant to this.